nobody knows why the tarians first came
to the island of dragon Stone old
valyria was then at the height of its
power and the center of the Civilized
World which ended at the narrow sea
Westeros was a filthy Backwater with
seven Kings squabbling over borders and
minor glories so much for
Progress the island itself was and is
nothing it had no gold or gems to lure
the Ian nobility all it has is rock
mostly a shiny black stone too brittle
for war and too sharp for building the
targaryens called it Dragon glass I call
it
useless but the targaryens managed to
raise a castle here simpletons claim
they used ancient Valyrian sorcery
forgetting that the targaryens brought a
small army with them from esos there's
no magic in strong backs though
admittedly the Castle is unlike any in
westos for free you can now listen to
the entire audiobook Fire and Blood On
which house of the Dragon is based and
which covers the entire targaryan
history including current and future
events of House of the Dragon for free
with a notable trial using our Link in
the
description foreign and
strange if the targaryens ever regretted
their Baron Outpost and longed for the
Comforts of home the Doom made their
Folly permanent valyria collapsed into
the waves and was no more to look East
was to see the ruin of their Homeland
the greatest civilization before or
since but to look West as Aon realized
was to see a fertile land ripe for
Conquest perhaps even a new
valyria though good for little else
Dragon Stone was the perfect staging
point for a G's invasion of Westeros the
blackw bay granted easy access to the
continent the lands there were disputed
by Three Kingdoms the reach the iron
islands and the stormlands but their
capitals were far enough away that none
could mount a force before Aon got a
foothold even if their kings had been
able to stop bickering over whose
problem he
was then it was too late Aon had chosen
his first Camp well with the Bay to the
east the river to the South and Open
Fields to the north and west his army
would be impossible to take by surprise
a perfect sight for an invasion and one
day his Capital City King's
Landing aen targarian landed to our
South and as had many before him liked
the look of the riverlands my ancestor
Edmund Tully led the desertion of
riverlords to his cause and was rewarded
by getting to watch King Haron burn in
his own tower on the shores of the godai
due north of the Isis of faces Rises a
monument to arrogance and
cruelty heren
hall for a people who prided themselves
on their ships the Iron Men of old
seized any chance to leave them and
carved out a vast Kingdom from the
peaceful River
Lords the Empire reached its Zenith
under King Heron hor
called the black by those he terrorized
and by his own men though they meant it
proudly King Heron Enslaved the
riverlands to raise the mightiest
Fortress Westeros had ever seen a castle
that could Garrison a million men with
walls so vast that Winters would come
and go and besieging armies grow old and
gray before the castle fell five Towers
he ordered reaching into the heavens
like Gras in fingers a
monstrosity which he forced our people
to build for their own
subjugation but the very day the slaves
laid the last Stone Aon Taran and his
sisters arrived in the South when they
arrived with their small army Haron
laughed and shut the
gates Heron Hall would have its first
test and an easy one at
that it
failed Heron har could have withstood an
assault from all the armies in Westeros
combined but Heron learned that the
tallest and thickest walls meant little
to dragons for dragons fly the problem
with huge castles is they blind you to
what's outside both by their size and
the arrogance they
Inspire not that the ironborn ever
lacked for that they take pride in their
ignorance of every trapping of
civilization though any Baker could have
told them that fire turns stone walls
into an oven and so Haron the black
finally lived up to his name and the
riverlords swept the ironborn Back to
the Sea when Aon the Conqueror came to
the iron Island the priest king Loos
claimed his Divine father the iron
born's Drowned God had shown him Krakens
pulling aan ships into the deep no
Krakens ever arrived and even if they
had they wouldn't have stopped a and his
Dragons without wings of their own
confused Loos filled his pockets with
stones and walked into the sea to take
councel with his
father thousands followed him but
apparently the Drowned God didn't
appreciate a crowd their corpses washed
upon the iron islands for years when
Egon targaryan declared that Westeros
was now his King M the 9th allied with
King Lauren Lannister of the westerlands
together they fought to save Westeros
from another foreign Barbarian whose
family practices put decent to shame but
the dragons won and the Field of Fire
claimed M and all his sons grandsons and
brothers instead of using the castle for
what it was built to do Haren Tyrell
surrendered it to Egon without a
fight in exchange Harlen was given the
castle his family had served for
thousands of years
with all its attendant lands and
Lords for over a thousand years the
greenhand sons and grandsons ruled the
reach as house Gardener the offshoots of
his daughters grew into vast and
Powerful houses in their own right
except for house Terell we chose instead
to serve our gardener cousins Faithfully
as stewards to manage their stronghold
of high garden and the daily Affairs of
the reach our words are growing strong
and under our stewardship the reach did
just that as did we until a blundering
king almost cost us
everything Aon Targaryen had landed in
Westeros King M Allied us with the Roth
to repel the upstarts
Army one can only Marvel that King M did
not reconsider when he saw the living
dragons against
him perhaps he should have sought
counsel from his trusted stewards before
he set out then again perhaps he
did at the Field of Fire Aon and let us
not forget his sisters burnt the
combined armies of the reach and rock
King M paid for his misjudgment with his
life and that of his ancient
family in a day the reach had lost its
king its ruling house and most of its
Army thankfully for everyone my ancestor
Harland Terell had better sense until
the maesters sorted out the Intel among
M's cousins Haren the steward was acting
Lord of high Garden to ensure peace and
life in the reach he would yield the
castle to
Aon the other castles and families would
then follow as they had since the dawn
age aen had a continent to conquer and
the fertile reach was too valuable to
raise he accepted harland's proposal and
wel welcomed our lands into his kingdom
to show his gratitude aen entitled
Harland to high Garden the castle his
family had served for a thousand years
and made house Terell his wardens of the
South choosing us over older greater
families in the reach our house thus
owed everything to the
targaryens the Lannisters reigned as
kings of the rock for thousands of years
and worked to make it the Envy of the
rest of the Seven
Kingdoms our time as kings ended however
when Aon tarian otherwise known as Aon
the Conqueror arrived in Westeros with
his
army the last king of the rock King
Lauren Lannister joined forces with King
M Gardner the king of the reach together
with 60,000 men they met the Targaryen
host in open
battle history tells us that aegon
Unleashed all three three of his dragons
slaughtering 4,000 men at what came to
be known as the Field of
Fire King M himself was burned alive
that day and house Garder turned to Ash
with
him seeing both the threat and
opportunity the targaryens represented
Lauren wisely surrendered and aided Aon
in his further conquest of
Westeros the Lannisters were thus us
appointed Lords Paramount of the
westerlands and wardens of the West
titles we hold to this
day while Aon burned the kings of the
iron Islands The Rock and the reach his
fiercest commander and rumored brother
or his Baratheon set out to subdue the
stormlands no matter how Fierce a
warrior he was no one could have envied
his task storms end had since thousands
of years of war never fallen but argilac
the Storm King chose not to barricade
himself behind its walls and gave orys
the battle he must have hoped for Oris
slew arac and took arak's Castle Kingdom
daughter sigil and house words how
Baratheon became the lord of the
stormlands when aegon and his dragons
landed on Westeros the kings of The Rock
and the reach sent all their men to die
to defend their crown
torren Stark knelt to spare his people
the same fate he placed Duty above Pride
the South had already fallen to aegon
and his dragons only the north remained
my ancestor King torren Stark marched
the north down to the Trident and beheld
aon's army larger than torren own by
half and with three dragons circling
overhead many Northern Bannerman wanted
to attack anyway claiming Northern Valor
would carry the
others wanted to fall back to Mo Kalin
and make a stand
there but torren had heard how the
armies of The Rock and the reach had
burned on the field of fire and had seen
the fires still glowing beneath the
rubble of
haror he knelt and laid his ancient
Crown at aon's feet and Rose a king no
more but Lord of Winterfell and Warden
of the
north some Northerners still sneer at my
ancestor as the king who knelt
forgetting that because of torren
they're alive today to sneer their
ancestors didn't leave their burned
bones at the Trident and their Twisted
swords didn't fill aon's new
Throne no Army in the Seven Kingdoms can
match the pride and chivalry of the
Knights of the veil after all they were
the first true knights in Westeros until
the dragons changed the
game when aan the Conqueror landed in
West Russ the queen regent of the veil
shut the bloody gate against the tarians
and masted the Knights of the veil
behind it to lock it but fenia simply
flew her Dragon to a balcony of the eie
where the boy King was playing and gave
the boy a ride around the castle in
return for his mother's submission when
Aon the Conqueror landed in Westeros the
high septon locked himself in a sept for
seven days and seven nights finally the
Crone lifted her golden lamp and showed
him the path ahead head the high septon
himself would anoint and Crown aegon as
lord of the Seven Kingdoms and the faith
militant rallied behind aegon in
governing his newly United land yet
aegon and his sisters never wholly
accepted the faith the high septon had
conceded agon's marriages to his sisters
as a relic of his Valerian Heritage
which would soon
fade Aon targaryan sought to unite
Westeros as nimia had dawnn the other
six kingdoms fell quickly before his
dragons and ambition when his sister
wife Raines flew her Dragon South and
demanded our surrender as well princess
Maria Martel warned I will not fight you
nor will I kneel to you Dorne has no
King tell your brother that rainy is
threatened that the next time the
targaryens would come with Fire and
Blood Maria replied you may burn us my
lady but you will not Bend us break us
or make us bow this is dor you are not
wanted here return at your
peril rainy did and she died her Dragon
died all her soldiers died eventually
her brother the Conqueror conceded that
what nimia had done he could not undo
Generations later another foolish
targarian invaded Dorne he died as well
eventually we did join the Seven
Kingdoms but when we wanted and on our
terms